retour sur terre on va parler d'amour
avec le cinéma vous connaissez sûrement
sarah jessica parker l'héroïne blonde de
sex and the city vous connaissez sans
doute
hugh grant et bien ils sont réunis à
l'écran pour un film qui sort demain où
sont passés les morgan
comment raviver la passion c'est le
thème de cette comédie romantique
marie-jo juin le dr tobin est simple et
il la meilleure conseillère conjugale de
la vie au dîner les morgan couple de new
york et pure souche en pleine dérive en
effet en effectuer vos clients mais en
guise de dessert un meurtre donc ils
vont être les seuls témoins parce que
les morgan
pour échapper aux tueurs ils ont été mis
au vert par la police ou la protection
de foils attentionné avec hugh grant au
casting l'expert en comédie romantique
au palmarès féminin étonnant le succès
mais aussi bien j'en avais vraiment
rêver comme la plupart des femmes
d'ailleurs un jouet une comédie
romantique avec ring
c'était le top avec éthique de la new
yorkaise l'héroïne de sex and the city a
pris si peu le grand air tout comme hugh
grant byers aussi sauf sur le plat
qu'elle est pommes de terre maison
puisque maison et sauce grand-mère chose
apporte autre chose
non merci juste à dire de cholestérol à
la gueule et donc de la campagne sont
moins c'est à petit de l effort au
maximum quatre heures le temps d'une
partie de golf et retour à la ville le
silence à man ouest sera lente et dans
le wyoming l'aventuré souvent au coin du
bruit sous ce que tu dis yalouz derrière
toi sem en passe de devenir culte
celle de luz la spa
je voulais m'inscrire il adorait les
compliments on les adore tous nous les
acteurs
cet ours qui programment entre les
scènes dont le câliner on lui gratter le
vendre j'étais jaloux j'ai demandé au
réalisateur on rate la même chose avec
moi même et les morgan vont-ils se
retrouver le bonheur est il vraiment
dans le pré suivant l'expression
consacrée
bien sûr on est à hollywood sous une
bonne étoile